[Music]
nice to see some good news there yes
sure is crave that
yeah immunity yeah we could use it and
hopefully more on the way amid the grief
and loss there is also a reason to feel
hopeful about our efforts to beat this
pandemic the number of people
hospitalized for the virus is decreasing
in the u.s
new hospitalizations are down 62 percent
nationwide from last month
we're joined now by dr anthony fauci he
is president biden's chief medical
advisor
and the country's top expert on
infectious diseases dr fatchi good
morning
uh thanks so much for being with us i i
want to start by talking about this
this heartbreaking milestone i think way
back when
less than a year ago actually when the
pandemic began the worst case projection
was
about 240 000 deaths we're now
more than double that in less than a
year at any point during this
has that number particularly as the
enormity of that number really struck
you
well you know it's horrible when we said
as you said correctly back in the
late winter and early spring of 2020
when we gave the modeling number of 240
000 people thought that we were being
hyperbolic
about that and and and somewhat alarmist
and clearly that was not the case this
is a horrible
uh a landmark that that we've now
reached
and even though the numbers are coming
down as you've shown
on the deflection of cases and
hospitalizations
we really can't declare victory quite
yet
because we have vaccines that clearly
are the light at the end of the tunnel
but we know that there are variants out
there one of the variants
the one from the uk is taken care of
quite well
by the vaccine the other one from south
africa
is a bit more problematic the one from
the uk we know
transmits more efficiently even though
the vaccine
can do well against it so what does that
tell us
that tells us instead of saying look at
that curve it's coming down so nicely
we're out of the woods it tells us what
we need to do
for sure is continue the public health
measures
of mass squaring and all the things we
talk about all the time
as well as getting people vaccinated as
quickly
and efficiently as possible there's some
concerns that that
those variants could lead to to another
significant spike
do you see that happening that is
certainly possible and that's the point
i'm trying to make
if we just let our guard down and act
like well it's coming down
so nicely with that deflection all the
way down
that we can now relax our our efforts
if we do that we're in continual danger
of having another surge i don't think
it's inevitable
that we will have a surge but we need to
be prepared
and the way we can be prepared is doing
the things i just mentioned a moment ago
you recently said dr faucio over the
weekend that we could be
wearing masks till 2022. people started
groaning at that but i think we need to
get the news straight
and i always feel that you do that for
us what what do you mean exactly by that
what does getting back to normal look
like for you and do you think it is 2022
gail the the point i was trying to make
is that
people ask you to make a projection when
there are so many
variables in there that are
unpredictable so when i said we might be
i didn't say we absolutely are going to
be where i'm saying it
is quite conceivable that if we actually
go into the fall in the winter and there
is still
a degree of virus in the community
despite the fact that many people have
been vaccinated
we certainly will likely very likely be
much better off
then than we are now but it is
conceivable
that there will be enough virus in the
community
that in order to be extra safe we may
have to be wearing masks
under certain circumstances that's the
only point that i was making i was not
trying to scare people
i'm saying we've got to be prepared that
variables are there and we could get
another surge
as i was just mentioning with anthony we
could have another surge right now
i don't think we will i hope we won't
but we've got to be prepared for it
that's
what i meant by don't just give up on
public health measures
because we're going in the right
direction well you certainly have a
front row seat to all of this you more
than anybody know how bad this is
um you're always on top of it but i'm
wondering
what sort of gets you through and i'm
not looking for a oh woe is me story
from dr fauci because i know that's not
your nature
but how do you get through this have
there been times that you've just said
this is a lot i had no idea it was going
to get
this bad well you know
when you're dealing with pandemic
outbreaks and infectious diseases
like a respiratory borne illness that
has such an extraordinary capacity
to transmit from person to person you
should never
ever underestimate it i mean you could
make projections like we do all the time
based on the current knowledge but
things
change and things shift so the way i get
through it
is by just saying focus like a laser
beam
on what the task is and how you get
through it
doctor you know don't celebrate and
don't just give up just
keep going dr fauci is there ever a
moment where you even have the time to
get emotional about this yeah
no anthony i don't i mean and that's the
point it isn't that i'm a very cold
person
but you can't let emotions drive
what you do i mean you have a test this
is a very this is
historic in nature what we're facing
people decades and decades from now will
be talking about what we all went
through
this past year there's no time for
emotion you
you absolutely need to be empathetic i
mean the
the thing you showed there with all of
those people
real people behind each of those deaths
you can't let that go by you can be
empathetic
but you don't want to get crippled by an
emotional response you've got to be
just focusing on what's important to do
yeah all those numbers are people and
that's why you can't say enough
wear your mask right and we appreciate
all that you do dr anthony fatchi thank
you so much
for being with us this morning